hillary clinton becoming the latest
democrat to discover that you go broke
when you go woke clinton making the case
that democrats focus on activist causes
could cost them dearly in november quote
look the most important thing is to win
the next election the alternative is so
frightening that whatever does not help
you win should not be a priority and
cnn's van jones thinks democrats are
completely out of touch with voters
if you pull out the working class you've
got people who are very well educated
and very well off those people talk
funny latinx i've never met a latinx
i've never met a bipoc i've never met
you know all this this weird stuff that
these highly educated people say it's
bizarre nobody talks that way at the
barber shop the nail salon uh the the
grocery store the community center but
that's how we talk now so that's weird
you know what's interesting is that and
he says everything that makes sense i
saw you nodding your head greg i mean is
is he the kind of guy that can convince
the democrats that they have to really
reverse course can they do it
yeah like if if any of us said that we'd
be called a bigot or something like that
but i love that moment
because it felt like he he
wasn't talking to the cnn host right he
was describing them to their face
you noticed the cricket eater just went
totally silent you could actually hear
the crickets in her stomach but it was
wonderful meanwhile hillary is only
right is right but only because she sees
it as a political error not a greater
error that creates human suffering like
if you actually had your ear to the
ground or saw what we were seeing with
crime and and and how wokism has
displaced so many major concerns
she would have acted sooner but because
she only sees things through a political
lens it's only we better do something
because we could lose that bothers me
because you should care whether you win
or lose don't you agree with greg harold
i mean when she says whatever does not
help you win should not be a priority
and now she's saying that defunding the
police is only hurting democrats why
didn't she say that two
two years ago a year and a half i think
if you look back she i think she did say
she did say something but i don't
necessarily disagree with greg i think
that
that
but politicians are motivated by
politics so whatever their motivation as
long as they want to do the right thing
the only thing democrats should be
focused on it's twofold the economic
challenges facing people around their
kitchen tables and the concerns that
people have about their safety and
security which is crime and border
security if you focus on those things
and stop trying to come up with new
names and new titles for things that
frankly i don't quite understand uh if
we do that we not only have a better
chance of winning we will actually
respond to the needs of people and our
politics will get better and more whole
if we do that jesse isn't that what a
what a candidate who's a trojan horse
does like it look at it this way that
you know what whatever doesn't help you
you should it should not be a priority
in other words say what they want you to
say and then when you get in get rid of
the trojan horse and you can deal with
all the extras well that was in the
wikileaks with crooked she had a public
position and a private position on the
same issue what's a bipoc or a buy box i
don't know what is that i know tupac
i've never heard that yeah yeah
i've never even heard of that and what
is latinx what does the x stand for why
isn't it latino or hispanic what does
latinx mean do you know
don't look at me okay someone has to
know what that means
i'm avoiding your oh you're just your
questions to the clouds right now i'm
thinking about notes for the next
segment just to be safe yep
there's something to be safe about i
said the same thing on prime time last
week no one says this
okay all right dana you want to wrap it
up sure i'll make two points one is that
the left is eating itself alive and
people like van jones and hillary are
trying to tell them that but one of the
funniest anecdotes about latinx is that
last week there's a democrat of new york
richie torres congressman and he said um
he said nobody actually uses the phrase
but then people pointed out that his
twitter account had had you several
times and that's why you're young your
young staff should not do your twitter
account but also how is it that hillary
clinton is on a media tour
and no one has asked her about being the
person who gave the go-ahead yeah russia
hoax i said come on media let's yeah the
program oh but they got over it i mean
they're past that i went to brian
kilmeade i want you to do me a favor i
want you to click to subscribe to the
fox news youtube page this is the only
way that i know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on fox you can get it
all here on youtube so subscribe right
now